we have been telling you a lot about the
Dalai Lama's visit to Canada this week
and today the man they call his holiness
is giving a speech in Toronto both the
art of happiness it's something we all
aspire to write the pursuit of happiness
but while the dalai lama calls it an art
you might say my next guest thinks of it
more as a science or a skill something
we could quantify and as a numbers guy
he should know John Halliwell is a
renowned economist he's with the
Canadian Institute for Advanced Research
he's also giving a speech on happiness
tomorrow in Vancouver John Halliwell
joins me now John how rich are you and
how happy are you I'm happy and it's not
because of richness and communication is
good even across the country with a
smile it's even better you know so many
people believe that money will make us
happier it gives you the freedom to do
what you want some call it access why do
you disagree well the evidence shows
we've now started going back and redoing
all the assumptions of which more or
less of being that material prosperity
was everything we asked people how happy
they are with their lives and then try
and find out what's true about their
lives it turns out that income is
important especially at the lower levels
of income to give that kind of freedom
you talk about but what's very important
in all the evidence and this is very
much the kind of thing that the Dalai
Lama concentrates on is the social
context so that the times people people
spend with each other especially in
friendly interactions building up the
trust Trust is enormously important let
me give you one number you want to have
a number to take away sure moving up on
the workplace where you spend your day
if you're asked to rate the trust in
management in the scale of one to ten
moving up just one point on that ten
point scale has the equivalent effect on
your life satisfaction as a thirty
percent difference in income well that's
pretty big thirty percent difference in
income for one point on the trust scale
just so so there are a lot of people who
may not quite realize why there
and happy as they are and they better
start thinking about it it's too easy to
think that it's because you don't have
another vehicle that of the sort that's
parked on top of a Mesa and the ads but
it probably is that you've shortchanged
yourself in terms of your social
connections reaching out doing things
for other it turns out there's a lot of
now experimental evidence showing that
people who one way or another or put in
circumstances that enable them to do
things for other people are much happier
than they would have been had they not
one of my colleagues has done
experiments where people are given money
on the one hand and asked to use it to
make themselves happy on the other hand
they're instructed to give it away it
turns out the people who are instructed
to give it away after afterwards are
happier than the ones who had everything
open to them as possibilities that's
pretty powerful evidence it supports
other evidence that in fact people miss
predict the amount of life satisfaction
they're going to get from material
things and underestimate the pleasure
they'll get from trusting interactions
with others so how do you explain why
most people believe then the money will
make them happy I mean are we all fools
well there is this systematic error
people make so in some sense it really
means it needs people like the Dalai
Lama speaking out and asking people to
think about their life in a different
way a lot of them will do that and when
they do it they'll find out it makes a
difference and they'll realize that a
number of the assumptions they've had
some of them coming from ads but some of
them just inbuilt and through habit are
wrong and they can make a better life
for themselves and especially for others
by reaching out in these ways looking
ahead global warming is one of those
issues that's really going to be dealt
with when people re-examine their
lifestyles and think in terms of less
materially based progress it'll come and
the more people realize that they're
actually going to be happier with an
alternative lifestyle the more likely
they are to do it in a willing way and
be pleased with the consequences you
know what makes me happy when my kids do
the homewood do their homework when they
help with the dishes when you know my
neighbors say hello to me in the morning
those kinds of things
make me happy but give me a tip for
being even happier for being ecstatic
for waking up in the morning and saying
oh my goodness I can't believe I'm just
alive I'm so happy what's your tip a
random act of kindness for somebody else
it's to reaching out to help others that
gives the unexpected and double boosts
of course it makes them feel better as
you've just described but it makes you
feel better even more so good advice